eight news now viewers letting us know
about rats being spotted at acacia park
in henderson sally jaramillo tells us
why we're seeing more rodents at parks
all across the valley
the rat population in the valley is
growing while you may have noticed them
around your yard they're invading parks
too pest control experts say the rodents
are usually drawn to areas with
vegetation fruits palm trees and pet
waste basically it's really always rat
season in las vegas kevin raz with j as
pest control says there's not one place
in the valley without them the main
reason we are having more issues in the
residential areas when restaurants got
closed down
the ruins had to find a new food supply
rats will travel about a 400 yard radius
for a new food supply once they find a
solid food supply then they find a
dwelling near to the food supply two
rodents could create about 30 babies a
year just last thursday rats being
spotted at acacia park i understand that
there's
rat problems in some of these parks i've
seen the videos of these rats and that's
very disturbing kenneth cypher has been
living in the area for almost 22 years
and says he came across the video
through nextdoor app he visits paseo
verde park in the morning every day and
is concerned for his furry friend they
need to
do something to get rid of those rats
in that park city of henderson parks
operation manager kirk neiman tells me
they immediately took action on august
16 by placing bait control boxes in the
area in a statement he says quote it is
highly advised that wildlife not be fed
at our local parks because this can
attract an increase of unwanted pests we
appreciate our residents bringing this
issue to our attention as we strive to
have quality and premier parks for
everyone to enjoy unquote as the
population girls in the desert areas
diminish rats will be living among us
reporting from acacia park in henderson
sally jaramillo 8 news now
so some other tips here to control rats
that might be in your neighborhood don't
feed birds don't feed your dogs or your
cats outside and also be sure to keep
that doggie door closed the last thing
you want is a little unexpected surprise
coming into your house